we have the the Supreme Court is going
to be taking up a case on gun rights and
so throughout all of this if one thing
can be said it's that we have record gun
sales you know we're seeing more
first-time gun buyers than than you know
record-breaking first-time gun buyer uh
gun buyers people want to defend
themselves and now there's the huge news
where gun rights Advocates are really
excited the Supreme Court is going to
rule on whether or not the right to keep
in bear arms exists outside of your home
but I do think it's funny that a lot of
people think it's going to be a positive
and the left seems to think it's going
to be a negative probably because the
court is
I guess on paper six to three even
though it's probably more likely five to
four there's a good possibility that
they rule against gun rights and based
on the track record we've seen over the
past couple of years it seems more
likely to me that the Supreme Court is
going to rule we don't have the right to
keep in bear arms I I don't understand
the people in the gun Community who are
just assuming that this is going to be a
positive outcome on this case it's I
mean were they happy with how the
Supreme Court dealt with the election
issues after the presidential election
because they basically just washed their
hands of the whole affair
maybe that was appropriate maybe not I'm
not an expert in election law not even
really an expert in gun law my expertise
is use of force law uh but you know
politics is Downstream of culture and to
think that you could lose the culture
lose the legislature lose the executive
branch and somehow the Supreme Court's
going to step in with a cape and save
you at the end strikes me as an
unrealistic expectation for any kind of
sustained Society
I'm looking at everything that's going
on you know with uh we've been talking a
lot about the Chauvin trial and
frankly the Injustice I mean people the
juror flat out saying she was scared of
riots and destruction I think that's all
you need to hear but obviously you can
see with your own eyes how it was
influenced in the jury
now we have the very real prospect that
come well you know it could be good it
could be bad but I'm I'm sorry if I'm
being pessimistic but come October it's
October 4th I think is when they're
gonna uh hear the hear the case they
could come out and take away our rights
and I think that's that's the trend so
far things have been just seemedly
seemingly seemingly getting worse in
terms of our rights in these areas well
I think the worst case scenario is not
that the Supreme Court says you can't
conceal carry anymore if you're allowed
to do it currently in your state they're
not going to take away a right but what
they would do is leave on the table the
option that hey if a state does if a
state wants to take away that right
they're privileged to do that New Jersey
doesn't want to give you a concealed
carry permit New York doesn't
uh Marilyn doesn't I'm not sure how
things work here but if the state
decides that you basically don't have a
right to carry a firearm outside of your
home the state's free to do that it
wouldn't affect you if you live in a
state where you're currently allowed to
carry unless of course the politics in
your state changes like in my home state
of Colorado they just passed some new
gun control laws in the last week or so
the state is becoming more like
California less than the Colorado I
moved into I don't expect gun laws to
get better there over time and if they
know they have the permission of the
Supreme Court to crank down and diminish
the right to keep and bear arms I expect
that they'll take advantage of that so
I'm curious though by what logic could
they
could the Supreme Court say the right to
keep in bear arms doesn't exist outside
of your home well there's no logical
basis but if you read any of these
Second Amendment decisions that favor
gun control especially like decisions
out of the ninth circuit for example in
California read the decision it's not a
legally reasoned decision it's what I
call word salad they're just making
noises it's like listening to someone
argue with their spouse and one of them
is being completely unreasonable just to
kind of score points on the other
they're just saying what they think they
need to say in order to justify
affirming infringement of the Second
Amendment but it's not based on reason
these are emotional not rational
decisions so like talking about mass
shootings and things like that
it's arguments like well why would you
ever need more than like six rounds in a
gun right which is the what New York
state had for some time maybe still it
was a six round what maximum limit but
wasn't it you could have like a 10 round
magazine but you can only put six months
only Six Bullets in it I mean and by the
way it's also important to keep in mind
that of course none of these laws none
of them actually affect Bad actors Bad
actors don't obey gun laws they don't do
background checks they buy their cars
out of the trunks uh guns out of the
trunks of cars they or they send their
girlfriends or mothers into the gun
store to buy the gun as a straw purchase
they don't have any respect for magazine
limits they don't care about not being
allowed to carry in a school zone They
are criminals which means they don't
obey the law so all these if one of the
criteria for infringing appropriately on
a constitutional right is supposed to be
at least it will accomplish the desired
effect well then gun control laws by
their very nature can't do that because
they don't affect the the criminal actor
so we've got an erosion of the criminal
justice system and an erosion of the
right to self-defense is the goal just
to destroy the country
is that hyperbolic
I don't think the people making those
arguments would claim that's the goal
but I believe from their perception the
goal is the accumulation of political
capital for some and frankly just
straight up Financial capital for others
and they are gaining political capital I
mean they get elected to these offices
they get put in charge they are making
the decisions and if people don't like
those decisions they would need to elect
other
politicians but they don't they don't
because most people aren't paying
attention most people don't care that's
the interesting thing about the whole
vote argument are you familiar with
Starship Troopers very much so a service
guarantee citizenship is that what it
was so uh we have a country right now
where the right to vote is
what's the what's the right word
um voting is becoming increasingly more
and more Universal to the point where
the Democrats have argued that 16 year
olds should have a right to vote my
argument has been like well I'm not
saying it should it should be you know
uh impossible to vote or we should go
back to the way it was where it'd be a
landown or anything but I certainly
think at the very least you have to
choose to vote if you want to vote right
so we see the unsolicited mail-in bouts
being sent to people they're not even
choosing to vote and they're getting
sent to balance so they're gonna I don't
know whatever sure right so politics and
public policy are not my area of
expertise but I would note that it's to
my mind it's an open question whether
Universal democracy is a system that can
work uh there's a legitimate concern
that once the majority of 51 percent
realizes they can simply vote themselves
the resources of the 49 percent
that you don't have a functioning
Society anymore because the 49 will not
be subjugated like that they will not
accept that the U.S was set up to have a
Bill of Rights partly to constrain the
government and its ability to infringe
on our natural rights but also to
provide protections for the minority so
just having 51 percent did not entitle
you to do anything you wanted there were
constraints on the government for just
that purpose
it's interesting because I often you
hear the argument from many Democrats
more of the corporate uh type that you
know the these the a fringe minority has
50 Senate seats or whatever you know
it's like you look at these states like
Wyoming and they got two senators and
it's like right because you're not
supposed to have the right to oppress
the minority it's supposed to be that
compromise is required and one state
doesn't get to tell another state what
to do just because there's more people
living there it's not a direct democracy
well also the Senators who were not
originally voted by a popular vote the
senators were not supposed to be
representing the people the senators
were representing the states the states
as independent political entities the
House of Representatives represented the
people House of Representatives right
the senators were the political actors
for the state themselves as separate
political entities in conflict with the
federal government
well now everything is just slowly
broken apart I think it was uh Ben sass
is that his name he said we should
repeal I think it was the 17th that's
the one that made the Senate Senators
elected by the people as opposed to
appointed by the state I think you're
correct yeah so it was interesting when
I saw that because it's an interesting
interesting argument if you were at the
local level voting for your local
politicians if you elected the right
people they would appoint the right
Senator you'd be happy with it but
what's happened now is no one even knows
who their local politicians are they
have no idea who represents their County
or I mean even their state well one of
the Dynamics I think we increasingly see
is that
if you wanted to buy elections you
wanted to buy politicians just with
money not no popular support for those
people uh you wouldn't Target a thousand
small elections you target a handful of
big elections Governors presidents and I
think we're seeing a lot of states where
the legislature may be Republican Maybe
by a large majority and somehow they
have a Democrat Governor right how does
that happen well it happens because
money comes in to support that Democrat
politician to win that single race you
focus all your energies on that race you
let the other team win all the smaller
elections because as long as you hold
that executive branch office you can
veto whatever the legislature does
unless you're able to override your veto
but it's a disproportionate amount of
power than if you expended that money in
a bunch of little races and came up with
only 49 then you effectively have no
power this is why I'm a big fan of or at
least I I like to entertain the idea
that we don't allow people to donate
outside of their outside of their their
districts where they live where they
declare residency because you look at
someone like ocasio-cortez and she gets
Millions you know plus from outside of
her District pretty sure the same is
true for Marjorie Taylor green not a fan
of any of it the people who live in the
area should be the ones making the
decisions instead people are dumping
money not only into the donations of the
candidate themselves but into
commercials in those districts to swing
these elections and then you get people
in Hollywood going into Republican areas
and getting Democrats to win these races
right so how do you stop that right I
mean I I understand the motivation
behind a lot of this election funding
regulation laws that are passed I just
don't ever see it being effective
because there's always ways to work
around it and then there's non-monetary
ways to support a politician that you
can't do anything about if movie stars
are going to come in and campaign for
one person running for an election
that's going to have an influence if
only because they'll get TV time it's
effectively free TV commercial space
exactly for that politician and I don't
see any way to stop that from happening
you're right right and and for man this
show you know Ian brought this up the
last time we talked about it well by by
the nature of having a show with viewers
it would give me more power over anyone
else because I can do a show from
wherever I want and speak who I think is
the right person to win and it's power
it's powerful it's influence so it's
it's difficult what ends up happening is
we have a system where the people of of
New York's 14th did not legitimately in
my opinion or I should say didn't uh
what's the right word I want to say uh
knowledgeably right like like they
didn't understand what they were voting
for fairly and I don't mean to single
out aoc's District it's basically every
District save a few smaller ones in
certain areas no no one really cares to
fight over but many of these people are
just given propaganda it's it's
Republicans and Democrats every single
at there's there's very little honesty
in politics period right so what
percentage of the populace who can vote
votes anyway like in a presidential
election is it even something like that
I think it was uh it was more than half
this time and how many do it in a pro
forma basis where they're just hey it's
my obligation I'll just show up and and
vote they're not really informed about
the issues and that's on the higher
level races so when you get to the lower
races like we talked about earlier with
who your local prosecutor is they have
no idea who those names are none and so
if somebody can drop in a few TV
commercials in that District they just
became the prosecutor in that District I
wish it was possible to say hey your
vote doesn't count unless it's a Well in
4 formed decision but we don't have a
mechanism for doing that
service guarantees citizenship I'm only
I'm only uh I'm actually I wouldn't say
half kidding 75 kidding I like the idea
of having some kind of Civic requirement
for being involved in in Civics in some
capacity but I say 75 kidding because I
wouldn't know how you'd Implement that
right how would this restrict certain
people who shouldn't be how would it you
know not restrict those who should be
none of us would go out to our local
supermarket and canvas the first 20
people we meet to ask them how they
should run their own household right
right what should I wear today you're
not going to ask other people what
should I invest my money in because
you'll get lunatic responses but all
those people
get to elect your government for you
right does that make sense I don't know
in our system of government that's the
public policy decision well I mean the
human beings have had different systems
throughout history uh I'm not sure
Universal Democrat majority rules
everything uh polity is one that's
long-term sustainable no it's not right
now the cult worship thing where like
you put one person in power and then
that one person becomes like the cult
leader like Ron Rand Paul he's a target
for bribes and they just get massive uh
investors all of them I just picked him
randomly Brand's like one of the only
ones I like somebody else he's still
bribable like like a corporation comes
in with 60 million or take them out to
dinner or lunch and they want to fund
his pack or his campaign and not not ran
not you any any of these people so
that's like a a weak point in our system
is that we have these individuals that
can be bribed and bought and Commercial
it's not so simple though when when
Marco Rubio was was doing a town hall
they questioned him they said I think it
was Rubio it might have been Ted Cruz
they were like you're getting money from
the NRA and he's like yeah they just
give me money because they like what I
already do they're not bribing me but
the perspective was no you've been
bribed by them it's like no I'm pro-gun
so they gave me money because they want
me to win but this is as this is just
another way of saying they're all human
beings I mean if you look at the Roman
Empire during Caesar he had the same
drivers he needed money he went to war
because that's how you acquired money he
had to pay off debts debts he
accumulator by running for elections and
getting political favors this is just a
normal this is what people do this is
how you work with other people to build
political Capital it's not because
everyone's a perfect and pure in the in
the in their hearts but you know you
know I think the problem is we are
seeing an increasing Detachment from
Community where you have judges or
prosecutors or individuals who just say
I don't care about my neighbor and I
don't care about my country I think the
bigger problem is we're becoming more
emotionally driven and I think that's
largely because of the way social media
works today I think the the news media
has always been a powerful influencer
serve how people see the world I mean
William Hurst bought newspapers so he
could influence the world because he
could people only know what they see
they know what they read if they don't
see it and read it it doesn't exist it's
invisible to them so what they see
written and how they see it portrayed
becomes their lived reality and the era
but that was when you might get a
morning paper or an evening paper or see
the news at six o'clock or ten o'clock
for 30 minutes at a time now we're all
immersed in this stream of propaganda
and emotive clicking and baiting all day
long I mean personally I've taken the
social media apps off my smartphone just
to not be constantly interrupted and
subject to that if this if these social
media platforms were drugs is there any
doubt they would be controlled
substances is it any doubt you'd have to
be 21 or 38 or 42 before you could
legally access that kind of content
their drugs and there would only be a
few that would be legal like alcohol it
would be YouTube right or Facebook or
Twitter and all the other ones would be
controlled I think we're on the schedule
I think I think the internet as we know
it is has been ending for some time I
think you know is the wild west several
you know 10 20 years ago now it's
becoming more and more corporatized
we're seeing you know YouTube lock
everything down they're picking the
winners and the losers they're getting
rid of a lot of what they don't like
Twitter's doing the same thing they're
trying to homogenize and create a
monoculture
now I will add one last thing um what's
going on in Florida with this uh this
this Billet passed the senate about
censorship is going to be the it's it's
like a nuclear bomb being dropped in
social media and the internet because
the way I understand it this would end
Wikipedia as we know it would be just
gone Wikipedia can't exist because they
wouldn't be able to remove news sources
they deem unreliable because that would
violate the law which says you can't
remove a journal Tech Enterprise for
their content or opinions
but the politicians who voted for that
can they realistically stay politicians
if they're demonized by social media if
they're Outcast if they're removed from
those platforms when even the sitting
president of the United States has
trouble with social media platforms if
you're a local politician in Florida and
you can't Facebook or tweet or use
social media to communicate with your
constituents but your opponent in the
race can do you really stand a chance
that's why they passed the law or that's
why it's it's almost it's going through
it went to the Senate that's why Rhonda
sandis wants to sign it because it has
to be done now before it's too late and
it may already already be too late and
if if they've done this back in 2018
when I recall when I called the
Republicans too stupid to deal with the
problem to save their own careers and
then sure enough they ended up losing
what like 30 something seats
so there it is thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time